there's no reason to think that the
ocean ends just beyond your horizon and
likewise there's no reason to think that
the aftermath of our big bang
um ends
just
at the boundary for we can see indeed
there are quite strong arguments
that it probably goes on about a hundred
times further
it may even go on so much further
that uh all combinatorials are
replicated and uh there's another set of
people like us sitting in a room like
this
the following is a conversation with
lord martin reese emeritus professor of
cosmology and astrophysics at cambridge
university and co-founder of the center
for the study of existential risk
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's martin reese
in your 2020 scientific american article
you write that
quote today we know that the universe is
far bigger and stranger than anyone
suspected so
what do you think are the strangest
maybe the most beautiful
or maybe even the most terrifying things
lurking out there in the cosmos
well of course we're still groping for
any detailed understanding of the remote
parts of the universe
but of course what we've learned in the
last few decades
is really two things first we've
understood that the universe had an
origin
about 13.8 billion years ago in a
so-called big bang a hot 10 states whose
very beginnings are still shrouded in
mystery and also we've learned more
about the extreme things in it
black holes neutron stars explosions of
various kinds and one of the most
potentially exciting discoveries in the
last 20 years mainly the last 10 has
been the realization that most of the
stars in the sky are orbited by retinues
of planets
just as the sun is orbited by the earth
and the other familiar planets and this
of course makes the night sky far more
interesting what you see up there aren't
just points of light but they're
planetary systems and that raises the
question could there be life out there
and so that
is an exciting problem for the 21st
century so when you see all those lights
out there you immediately imagine all
the planetary worlds that are
around them and they potentially have
all kinds of different
lives
living organisms life forms or well in
history that we don't know at all we
know that these planets are there we
know that
they have masses and um
orbits rather like the planets of our
solar system but we don't know at all
if there's any life on any of them i
mean it's entirely logically possible
that life is unique to this earth
doesn't exist anywhere on the other hand
uh it could be that the origin of life
is something which happens
routinely given conditions like the
young earth
in which case there could be literally
billions of places in our galaxy where
some sort of biosphere has evolved and
uh settling
where the truth lies between those two
extremes
is a challenge for the coming decades
so certainly we're either
lucky to be here or very very very lucky
to be here i guess that's there it is
that's the difference
uh
where do you fall
your own estimate your own guess on this
question are we alone in the universe do
you think
i think we're foolish to give any firm
estimate because we just don't know and
that's just a example of how
we are depending on greater observations
and also incidentally in the case of
life we've got to take account of the
fact that
as i always say to my scientific
colleagues biology is a much harder
subject than physics and most of the
universes we know about could be
understood by physics
but
we've got to remember that even the
smallest living organism
an insect is far more complicated with
layer on
complexity
than
the most complicated star or galaxy
you know that's the funny thing
about physics and biology
the dream of physicists in the 20th
century and maybe this century is to
discover the theory of everything
and there's a sense by
that once you discover that theory you
will understand everything
if we unlock the mysteries of how the
universe works would you be able to
understand
how life emerges from that
fabric of the universe that we
understand i think the phrase theory of
everything is very misleading
because it's used to describe a theory
which unifies the um three
laws of microphysics electricity
magnetism the weak interaction with
gravity so it's a important step forward
for particle physicists
but the lack of such a theory doesn't
hold up any other scientists
anyone doing biology or most of physics
is not held up at all
through not understanding subnuclear
physics they're held up because they're
dealing with things that are very
complicated
and that's especially true of anything
biological so what's holding up
biologists
is not a lack of the so-called theory of
everything uh it's the
inability to understand things which are
very complicated
what do you think will understand first
how the universe works or how the human
body works
deeply like from a fundamental deep
level well i think the perhaps we can
come back to it later that there
are
only limited prospects of ever
being able to understand with unagi as
human brains the most fundamental
theories linking together all the forces
of nature i think that may be a
limitation of the human brains
but i also
think that
we can perhaps aided by computer
simulations
understand a bit more of the complexity
of nature but even understanding a
simple organism
from the atom up is very very difficult
and i think extreme reductionists
have a very misleading perception they
tend to think that uh in a sense we are
all solutions as far as equation etc
but that
isn't the way we ever understand
anything uh it may be true
that we
are reluctant in a sense if we believe
that that's the case we don't believe in
any special life force in living things
but nonetheless no one thinks that we
can understand a living thing by solving
schrodinger's equation to take an
example which isn't as complicated lots
of people study the flow of fluids like
water
why waves break why flows go turbulence
things like that this is a serious
branch of applied mathematics and
engineering
and in doing this you have concepts of a
viscosity turbulence and things like
that
now
you can understand quite a lot
about how water behaves and how waves
break
in terms of those concepts
but the fact that any
breaking wave is a solution
of spherical's equation for tens of 30
particles
even if you could solve that which you
clearly can't would not give you any
insight so the important thing is that
every science has its own irreducible
concepts
in which you get the best explanation
so it may be in chemistry it's things
like valence um in
biology
the
concept in cell biology
and in ecology there are concepts like
imprinting etc and in psychology there
are other concepts so in a sense the
sciences are
like a tall building
where you have
basic physics the most fundamental then
the rest of physics then chemistry then
cell biology etc
all the way up to the i guess economists
and the penthouse and all that
and we have that um
and that's true in a sense but it's not
true
that it's like a building in that it's
made
unstable by an unstable base because if
you're a chemist biologist or an
economist
you're facing challenging problems
but they're not made any worse
by uncertainty about subnuclear physics
and at every level just because you
understand the rules of the game or have
a some understanding of the rules of the
game doesn't uh
mean you know
what kind of beautiful things that game
creates
right so uh if you're interested in um
birds and how they fly uh then things
like uh um imprinting
the baby on the mother and all that and
uh things like that are what you need to
understand um you couldn't even in
principle
solve this vertical equation how an
albatross wanders for thousands of miles
of the southern ocean and comes back and
then coughs up food for its young
that's something we can understand in a
sense
and uh predict the behavior but it's not
because we can solve it on the atomic
scale you mentioned that there might be
some fundamental limitation to the human
brain yes that limits our ability to
understand some aspect of how the
universe works that's really interesting
that's
sad actually if if if to the degree it's
true it's sad so what do you mean by
that i would simply say that just as um
a monkey can't understand quantum theory
or even newtonian physics um there's no
particular reason
why the human brain should evolve to be
well matched to understanding a deepest
aspect of reality
and i suspect that there
may be aspects that we are not even
aware of
and couldn't really fully comprehend
but as an intermediate step towards that
one thing which i think is very
interesting possibility is the extent to
which ai can help us
i mean i think uh if you take the
example of
so-called theories of everything one of
which is string theory
string theory involves very complicated
geometry
and structures in 10 dimensions
and it certainly in my view on the cards
that
the physics
of 10 dimensions
very complicated geometry um
may be too hard for a human being to
work through
but could be worked through
by
an ai
um with the advantage of the huge
processing power
which enables them to learn world
championship chess within a few hours
just by watching games so there's every
reason to expect
that these um machines could help us to
solve these problems and of course if
that's the way we
came to understand whether the string
theory was right um it should be in a
sense frustrating because you wouldn't
get the sort of aha insight which is the
greatest satisfaction from doing science
but on the other hand
if um a machine churns away a 10
dimensional geometry figuring out all
the possible
origamis and bound up in extra
dimensions if it comes out at the end
spews out the correct mass of the
electron the fact that there are three
kinds of neutrinos something like that
you would know that there was some truth
in the theory
and so we may have a theory which we
come to trust because it does predict
things that we can observe and check but
we may never really understand the full
workings of it to the extent that we do
more or less
understand
how
most phenomena can be explained in a
fatal way because in case of quantum
theory many people would say
understandably there's some mystery if
you don't quite understand why it works
but there could be deeper mysteries when
we get to these unified theories where
there's a big gap between
what a computer can
print out for us at the end
and what we can actually grasp and think
through in our heads yeah it's
interesting that
the idea that there could be things a
computer could tell us that it's true
and maybe you can even help us
understand
why it's true a little bit but
ultimately it's still a long journey to
really deeply understand the whys of it
uh
yes that's the limitation of our brain
we can try to sneak up to it in
different ways given the limitations of
our brain have you i've gotten a chance
to spend the day at deepmind talk to
demus habess his big dream is to apply
ai
to the questions of science certainly to
the questions of physics have you gotten
a chance to interact with them well i
know quite well i've uh
he's one of my heroes certainly
and i remember i'm sure he would say
this and i remember the first time i met
him he said that he was like me he
wanted to understand the universe
but he thought the best thing to do was
to try and develop ai and then with the
help of ai he'd stand more chance of
understanding the universe yeah and i
think he's right about that so and of
course um although we're
familiar with the way his uh computers
play go and uh chess um
he's already made contributions to
science through uh
understanding protein folding better
than the best human chemists and so
already he's on the path to showing
ways in which computers have the power
to learn and do things by having a bit
to analyze enormous samples in a short
time
to do better than humans and so um i
think he would resonate for what i've
just said that it may be that uh in
these other fundamental questions the
computers will play a crucial role
yeah and they're also doing quantum
mechanical simulation of electrons
they're doing
uh control of of high temperature plasma
fusion reactors yes that's a new thing
which is very interesting they can
suppress the instabilities in these
tokamaks um better than any other way
yeah and it's just the march of progress
by ais and science
is
is making uh big strides do you think an
ai system will win a nobel prize in this
century what do you think
does that make you sad if i can digress
and put in a plug for my next book yes
it has a chapter saying why nobel prizes
do more harm than good yes so
on a quite separate subject i think uh
nobel prizes do a great damage to the
perception of the way science is done of
course if you ask who or what deserves
the credit for any scientific discovery
it may be often someone who has an idea
a team of people who work a big
experiment etc um and of course uh it's
the quality of the equipment
which is um crucial and certainly in the
subjects i do in astronomy um the
huge advantages we've had
come not from us being more intelligent
than aristotle was but through us having
far far better
data
from powerful telescopes on the ground
and in space and also
we
incidentally
is hugely in astronomy
from
computer simulations because um if you
are
a subatomic physicist then of course you
crash together the particles in the big
accelerator like the one at cern and see
what happens but
i can't crash together two galaxies or
two stars and see what happens but in
the virtual world of a computer
one can
do simulations like that and
the power of computers is such that
these simulations uh can
yield
a phenomena
and insights which we wouldn't have
guessed beforehand and the way we
can feel we're making progress and
trying to understand some of these
phenomena why galaxies have the size and
shape they do and all that is because we
can do simulations um tweaking different
initial conditions and seeing which
gives the best fit to what we actually
observe and so that's
a way in which we've made progress
in using
computers and incidentally uh we also
now need them to analyze data because
one thinks of astronomy has been
traditionally rather data-poor subjects
but the european satellite called gaia
has just put on line the um
speeds and colors and properties of
nearly two billion stars in the milky
way
fantastic analyses of and that of course
could not be done at all without just
the number crunching capacitors
computers
and the the new methods of machine
learning actually
love
raw data the kind that astronomy
provides organized structured raw data
yeah well indeed because the reason they
really have a benefit over us is that
they can
learn and think so much faster that's
how they can learn to play chess and go
that's how they can learn to diagnose
lung cancer better than the radiologist
because they can look at a hundred
thousand scans in the
in a few days whereas uh
no human radiologist sees that many a
lifetime
well
there's still magic to the human
intelligence to the intuition to the
common sense reasoning
uh well we hope so
for now what what's what is the new book
that you mentioned the book is called
if science is to save us it's coming out
in september
and it's on the um well
the big challenges of science um you
know um climate dealing with uh bio bio
safety and dealing with cyber safety and
also it's got chapters on the um uh way
science is organized you know
universities and academies et cetera
institutions and the the ethics of
science and um
and perhaps
and the limits yes yeah well let me
actually just stroll around the the
beautiful and the strange of the
universe uh over 20 years ago you
hypothesized that
we would solve the mystery of dark
matter by now
so unfortunately we didn't yet
first what is dark matter and
why has it been so tough to figure out
well i mean we learned that galaxies and
other large-scale structures
which are moving around but uh um
prevent them flying apart by by gravity
um would be flying apart
if they only contain the stuff we see
if everything in them was shining
and to understand how galaxies formed
and why they
do remain confined the same size
one has to infer
that there's about five times as much
stuff
producing gravitational forces than the
total amount of stuff in the gas and
stars that we see and that stuff is
called dark matter
um that's his leading name it's not dark
it's just transparent etc um and the uh
most likely
interpretation
is that it's a swarm of
microscopic particles
which have no electric charge
and the very small cross sections are
hitting each other and hitting anything
else so they swarm around
and we can detect their collective
effects and when we do computer
simulations of how galaxies form and
evolve
and how they emerge from the big bang
then
we get a nice consistent picture
if we put in
five times as much
mass in the form of these
mysterious dark particles and for
instance it works better if we think
they're non-interacting particles than
if you think they're a gas which would
have shock waves and things so we know
something about the properties of these
but we don't know what they are and um
the disappointment compared to my
guess 20 years ago um is that
particles answering this description
have not yet been found it was thought
that the big accelerator the large
hadron collider that cern was the
world's biggest might have found a new
class of particles which would have been
the obvious candidates and it hasn't
and uh um
some people say well dark matter can't
be there etc but what i would argue is
that there's a huge amount of
parameter space that hasn't been
explored um there are other kinds of
particles called axions which behave
slightly differently which are a good
candidate um and um there's a factor of
10 powers of 10
between the heaviest particles that
could be created by
the large hadron collider
and the heaviest particles which on
theoretical grounds could exist
without turning into black holes so
there's a huge amount of uh possible
particles which could be out there
as remnants of the big bang but which we
wouldn't be able to text so easily so um
the fact that we've got new constraints
on what the dark matter could be
doesn't diminish my belief that it's
there in the form of particles because
we've only explored a small fraction of
parameter space
so there's this search you're
literally
upon unintended are
searching in the dark
here in this giant parameter space of
possible particles you're searching for
i mean there could be all kinds of
particles it could be and the sum is
maybe very very hard to detect but i
think we can hope for um
some new theoretical ideas because um
one point which perhaps you'd like to
discuss more is about the
very early stages of the big bang
um and uh the situation now is that we
have a
outline picture for how the universe has
evolved um from
the time it was expanding in just a
nanosecond
right up to the present and we could do
that because
after nanosecond
the physics of the material
is in the same range that we can test in
the lab
after
a nanosecond the particles moving around
like those in the large hat or collider
if you wait for one second they're
rather like in the centers of the hotter
stars and
nuclear axes produce hydrogen helium etc
which fit the data so we can with
confidence extrapolate back to when the
universe was not a second old indeed i
think we can do it with as much
confidence as anything a geologist tells
you about the early history of the earth
and that's huge progress in the last 50
years but
any progress puts in sharper focus
new mysteries and of course
the new mysteries in this context are
why is the universe expand the way it is
why does it contain this mixture of
atoms and dark matter and radiation and
why does it have
the properties which allow galaxy to
form being fairly smooth but not
completely smooth and the answer to
those questions
are generally believed to lie in a much
much earlier stage of the universe
when conditions were much more extreme
and therefore far beyond
the stage when we had the foothold in
experiments very theoretical and so
we don't have a
convincing theory we just have ideas
until we have something like string
theory or some other clues to the ultra
early universe
that's going to remain speculative so um
there's a big gap and to say how big the
gap is um if we take the observable
universe out to a bit more than 10
billion light years um then when the
universe was a nanosecond old
that would have been squeezed down to
the size of our solar system
or compressed into that that volume
but the times we're talking about when
the key properties of the universe were
first imprinted
were times when that entire universe was
squeezed down to the size of a tennis
ball or baseball if you prefer
and to demerge from something
microscopic so it's a huge extrapolation
and it's not surprising that
since it's so far from our experimental
range of detectability
we are still groping for ideas
but you think first theory will reach
into that place and then experiment will
perhaps one day catch up well i think
simulation in a sense it's a combination
i think
what we hope for
is that um
there'll be a theory
which applies to the early universe
but which also has consequences which we
can test in our present day universe
like um
discovering
my neutrinos exist or things like that
and that's the thing which
as i mentioned we may perhaps need a bit
of ai to help us to calculate but yeah
but i think um the hope would be
that we will have a theory which applies
under the very very extreme early stage
of the universe but which gains
credibility and gains confidence because
it also manages to account for otherwise
unexplained features of
the low energy world of what people call
the standard model of particle physics
where there are lots of undetermined
numbers so it may help with that
so we're dancing between physics and
philosophy a little bit but what do you
think
what do you think happened before the
big bang
so this seems this feels like something
that's out of the reach of science
it's out of the reach of present science
because science develops and
as the front is advanced
then new problems come into focus that
couldn't even have been postulated
before i mean if i think of my own
career when i was a student
the evidence for the big bang
was pretty weak whereas now it's
extremely strong
but we are now thinking about the
reason why the universe is the way it is
and all that um so uh i i would put all
these things we've just mentioned in the
category of speculative science
um and i don't see a bifurcation between
that and philosophy um but of course to
answer your question um
if we do want to understand the very
early universe then we've got to realize
that
it may involve even more
counterintuitive concepts than quantum
theory does
because it's a condition even further
away from everyday
world than quantum theory is and
remember our lives
our brains
evolved
and haven't changed much since
our ancestors roamed the african
savannah and looked at the everyday
world um and uh it's rather amazing that
we've been able to make some sense of
the quantum micro world and of the
cosmos but uh
there may be some things which are
beyond us and certainly as we implied
they're things that we don't yet
understand at all and of course one
concept we might have to jettison
is the idea of three dimensions of space
and time just ticking
away a lot of ideas i mean i think
stephen hawking had an idea that talking
about
what's
what happened before the big bang it's
like asking what happens if you go north
from the north pole you know it somehow
closes off that's just one idea
um i don't like that idea but that's a
possible one um and uh
and so we just don't know um
what happened at the very beginning of
the big bang
were there many big bangs rather than
one etc
and
those are issues which
we may be able to
get some
foothold on
from some new theory
but
even then um we won't be able to
directly test the theories but i think
um
it's a heritage i think you have to be
able to test every prediction of a
theory let me give you another example
um
we take seriously what einstein's theory
says about the inside of black holes
even though we can't observe them
because
that theory has been vindicated in many
other places
in cosmology and black holes
gravitational waves and all those things
likewise if we had a theory
which
explains some things about the early
history of our big bang and the present
universe
then we would take seriously
the inference if it predicted many big
bangs not one even though we can't
predict the other ones so the example is
that we can uh take seriously a
prediction
if it's the consequence of a theory that
we believe on other grounds we don't
need to be able to uh detect
another big bang in order to take it
seriously it may not be a proof
but it's a good indication that uh
this is the direction where the truth
lies yeah if the theory is gain
confidence in other ways yes
where do you sense do you think there's
other universes
besides our own
those sort of well-defined theories make
assumptions
about the physics at the relevant time
and this time incidentally is 10 to the
power minus 36 seconds um or earlier
than that so this tiny sliver of time
and um there are some theories uh famous
one due to andre linday um the russian
cosmologists now at stanford called
eternal inflation um which did predict
um
an internal production of new big bangs
as it were and uh
that's based on specific assumptions
about the physics but those assumptions
of course are just hypotheses which
aren't vindicated but there are other
theories which
only predict one big bang so i think
we should be open-minded and not
dogmatic about these these options until
we do understand the relevant physics
but there are these different scenarios
are very different ideas about
about this but i think all of them have
the
feature
that physical reality is a lot more
extensive than what we can see through
our telescope i think even most
conservative astronomers would say that
because
we can see out with our telescopes to a
sort of horizon
which is about
depending on how you measure it by maybe
15 billion light years away or something
like that but that horizon of
observations
is no more physical reality
than the horizon around you if you're in
the ocean
and look at looking out at
your horizon there's no reason to think
that the ocean ends just beyond your
horizon and likewise there's no reason
to think that
the aftermath of our big bang
ends
just
at the boundary what we can see indeed
they're quite strong arguments
um that it probably goes on about 100
times further
they may even go on so much further
that uh all combinatorials are
replicated and
there's another set of people like us
sitting in a in a room like this every
possible combination of yeah
that could happen
well that's not logically impossible um
but but i think many people would accept
that it does go on
and contain
probably a million times as much stuff
as what we can see within the horizon
the reason for that incidentally is that
if we look as far as we can in one
direction and in the opposite direction
then the conditions don't differ by more
than one part in a hundred thousand so
that means that if we're part of some
finite structure
the gradient across the part we can see
is very small and so that suggests that
it probably does go on a lot further and
the best estimates say it must go on at
least 20 times further
is that
exciting or terrifying to you just the
spans of it all the wide
everything that lies beyond the horizon
that that example doesn't even hold for
earth so it goes way way farther and on
top of that just to take your metaphor
further with the on the ocean yeah while
we're on top of this ocean
not only can we not see beyond the
horizon
we also don't know much about the depth
of the ocean
nor the actual mechanism of observation
that's in our head yes
no i think there's another is all those
points you make yes yes but but i think
um
even the solar system is pretty vast by
human standards and so uh i don't think
the perception of this utterly vast
cosmos
need have any
deeper impact on us than just realizing
that we are
very small on the scale of the external
world
yeah
it's humbling though
it's it's humbling in in uh depending
where your ego is it's humbling and well
if you could be very unhumble indeed it
may make a difference but for most of us
i don't think it might be
much difference and uh well there's a
more general question of course about
whether um the human race as such
is something which is
very special
or if on the other hand um it's just one
of
many such species elsewhere in the
universe or indeed existing at different
times in our universe
it to me it feels
uh
almost obvious that the universe should
be full of alien life
perhaps dead alien civilizations but
just
the the vastness of space
and
it just feels
wrong
to think of earth as somehow special it
sure as heck doesn't look that special
when you the more we learn the less
special it seems
well i mean i don't agree with that as
far as life is concerned because uh
remember that we don't understand how
life began here on earth yes we don't
understand
although we know there are any evolution
of simple life to complex life we don't
understand uh what caused the transition
between complex chemistry and the first
replicating metabolizing entity we call
alive yes that's a mystery um and uh
serious physicists
and chemists are now thinking about it
but we that we don't know so we
therefore can't say was it a rare fluke
yeah which would not have happened
anywhere else or was it something which
uh involves the processes would have
happened in any other planet where
conditions were like they were on the
young earth
um so we can't say that now um
i think
many of us would indeed bet
that probably
some kind of life exists elsewhere but
even if um you accept that then um there
are many contingencies going from simple
life to
present day life and some
biologists like stephen j gould
thought that if you reround evolution
you'd end up with something quite
different
and maybe not with an intelligent
species so the contingencies in
evolution
may
militate against the emergence of
intelligence even if life gets started
in lots of places so i think these are
still completely open questions and
that's why it's such an exciting time
now
that we are starting to be able to
address these i mean i mentioned the uh
the fact that the origin of life
is a question that we may be able to
understand um and serious people are
working on it it's usually put in the
sort of too difficult box everyone knew
was important but they didn't know how
to tackle it or what exposed to do but
it's not like that now
and um that's partly because of clever
experiments but i think most importantly
because um we are aware that we can look
for life in other places other places in
our solar system and of course on the
exoplanets around other stars and uh
within 10 or 20 years
i think two things could happen which
would be really really important
we might with the next big telescope
be able to image some of the earth-like
planets around other stars
image right get a picture well actually
let me caveat that it take 50 years to
get a resolved image but but try to
detect the light because now of course
these exoplanets are detected by their
effects on the parent star they either
cause their parents start to dim
slightly when they transit across in
front of it and so we see the dips or
their gravitational pull makes the star
wobble a bit
so most of the the 5 000 plus planets
that have been found around other stars
they've been found indirectly by their
effects yes in one of those two ways on
the page you can still do a pretty good
job of estimating size
all those kinds of subjects the size and
the mass you can estimate um but uh um
but
detecting the the actual light from
one of these exoplanets hasn't really
built on yet exactly one or two very
very very bright big planets so maybe
like james webb telescope well james
webb may do this but even better will be
the european ground-based telescope
called unimaginative to the extremely
large telescope which has a 39 meter
diameter mirror 39 meters yeah mosaic of
800 sheets of glass and that will
collect enough light
from
one of these exoplanets around the
nearby star um to be able to um
separate out its light
from that of the star which is a
millions of times brighter and get the
spectrum of the planet
and see if it's got oxygen or
chlorophyll and things in it so that
that will come um james webb may may
make some some steps there um but
i think we can look forward to learning
quite a bit um in the next 20 years
because i like to say um supposing the
aliens looking at the solar system
then they see the sun as an ordinary
star they'd see
the earth as in carl sagan's life phrase
a pale blue dot
lying very close in the
sky to its star our sun and much much
much fainter but if they could
observe that dot
they could learn quite a bit
they could
perhaps get the spectre of the light and
find the atmosphere
they'd find the shade of blue was
slightly different depending on whether
the pacific ocean or lamas of asia was
facing them so they could infer the
length of the day and the oceans and
continents and maybe something about the
seasons and the climate and uh that's
the kind of
calculation
calculation under inference
we might be able to draw within the next
10 or 20 years about other exoplanets
and um
and evidence of some sort of
biosphere on one of them would of course
be crucial and it would rule out the uh
still logical possibilities that life is
unique but there's another way in which
this may happen in the next 20 years
people think there could be something
swimming under the ice of
europa and enceladus and probes are
being sent
to maybe not quite go under the ice but
detect the spray coming coming out to
see if there's evidence for organics in
that and
if we found any evidence for
an origin of life that happened
in either of those places that would
immediately be important because if
life has originated twice
independently in one planetary system
the solar system that would tell us
straight away it wasn't a rare accident
and must have happened billions of times
in the galaxy
at the moment
we can't rule out it being unique and
incidentally if we found life on mars
then that would still be ambiguous
because uh um people have realized that
this early life could have got from mars
to earth or vice versa on meteorites so
um if you found life on mars then some
skeptics could still say if it's a
single origin
but i think europa is far enough that's
far enough away
because yes so so that's why that would
be especially it's always the skeptics
that ruin a good party but
but we need them of course we need them
at the party we need some skeptics at
the party yeah um but boy would that be
so exciting to find life mm-hmm on one
of the moons yes
because
that's
that'll just be any kind of vegetation
or life um the question of the um aliens
of science fiction is a different matter
intelligent aliens
yeah but if you
have a good indication that there's life
elsewhere in the solar system
that means life is everywhere
yep and that yep
i don't know if that's terrifying or
what that is because if life is
everywhere
why is intelligent life not everywhere
why i mean you've talked about that most
likely
alien civilizations if they are out
there
they would likely be far ahead of us
the ones that would actually communicate
with us yes and that
um
again one of those things is both
exciting and terrifying you you've
mentioned that they're likely not to be
of biological nature
well i think
that's important of course again it's a
speculation but uh
in speculating about
um intelligent life and i
i take the search seriously in fact i
chair the uh committee that the um
russian-american investor yuri milner
supports looking for intelligent life
he's putting 10 million dollars a year
into a better equipment and getting time
on telescopes to do this and so i think
it's worthwhile even though i i don't
hold my breath for success it's it's
very exciting but but that does
leave me to wonder what
might be detected and um
i think
well we don't know we've got to be
reminded about anything we have no idea
what it will be and so any anomalous
objects or even some strange shiny
objects in the solar system or anything
we've got to keep our eyes open for but
i think um if we
ask
what
about a um
planet like the earth where evolution
had taken more of the same track
then as you say it wouldn't be
synchronized um if it uh had
lagged behind then of course it would
not have got too
advanced life
but it may
have had a head start it may have formed
on a plant around an older star okay but
then let's ask what would see um
it's taken nearly four billion years
from the first life to us
and we've now got this technological
civilization
which
could make itself
detectable um to any alien live
aliens out there
but i think most people would say
that this
civilization
of flesh and blood creatures in the
collective civilization may not last
more than a few hundred years more
i think that the
bad people may some people say
it will um kill itself off um but i'm
more optimistic and i would say
that sir
what we're going to have in future
is um
no longer the slow darwinian selection
but we're going to have what i call
secular intelligent design which would
be
humans
designing um
their progeny to be better adapted to
where they are
and
if they go to mars or something
somewhere they're badly adapted they
want to adapt a lot and so
they will adapt
but there may be some limits to what
could be done with flesh and blood and
so they may become
largely electronic
um
download their brains and have and be
exonic entities and if they're
electronic
then what's important is that they're
near immortal
and also they won't unless they want to
be on a planet with an atmosphere or
gravity they may go off into the blue
yonder and they and if they're near
immortal they won't be daunted by
interstellar travel taking a long time
and so um
if
if we
looked at what would happen on the earth
in the next millions of years
then there may be these electronic
entities which have been sent out and
are now far away from the earth
but still sort of burping away in some
in some fashion to be detected um and so
uh this um this therefore leads me to
think that um
if there
was another
planet which had evolved like the earth
and was ahead of us
uh it wouldn't be synchronized so he
wouldn't see a flesh and blood
civilization but we would see
these electronic progeny as it were um
and then this raises another question
because um
there's the famous argument against
there being um uh lots of aliens out
there which is that they would um come
and invade us and eat us or something
like that you know
that's a common idea uh which so fairly
is attributed to i've been the first to
say um and i think there's a um escape
clause to that because these um entities
yeah would be
say that they evolved by secular
intellectual design designed by their
predecessors and then designed by us
and
whereas darwinian selection requires two
things
it requires aggression
and intelligence
this future intel design um uh may favor
intelligence because that's what they
were designed for but it may not favor
aggression
and so these future entities they they
may be um
sitting deep thoughts
thinking deep thoughts
um
and uh not
being at all expansionists so they could
be out there
yeah um and we can't refute their
existence in the way the fermi paradox
is supposed to refute their existence
because um these would not be aggressive
or expansionist well maybe evolution
requires competition not aggression and
i wonder if competition can take forms
that are non-expansionary
so you can still have fun competing yeah
in the space of ideas
which maybe primarily adobe philosophers
perhaps yeah
[Laughter]
in in a way right it's a
it's an intellectual exercise versus a
sort of
violent exercise
so
what does this civilization on mars look
like so do you think
we would more and more you know maybe
start with some genetic modification and
then move to basically cyborgs
increasing integration of electronic
systems computational systems into our
bodies and brains this is a theme of um
uh my other new book out this year which
is called the end of astronauts at the
end of actually
co-written with my um
old friend and colleague from berkeley
don goldsmith and uh it's really about
um the the role of uh human space flight
versus sort of robotic space flies and
um just to summarize what it says um it
argues that the um
practical case for sending humans into
space
is getting weaker all the time
as robots get better and more capable
robots 50 years ago couldn't do anything
very much but now they could assemble
big structures on space or
um in space or on the moon and they
could probably do exploration
well present ones
uh on mars um can't actually um
do the geology but future ai will be
able to do the geology and already they
can dig on mars and so if you want to do
exploration of mars and of course
even more of them
enceladus said
europa where you could never send humans
we depend on robots
and they're far far cheaper because to
send a human to
mars requires
feeding them for 200 days on the journey
there and bringing them back and neither
of those are necessary for robots so the
practical case for humans is getting
very very weak and if humans go it's
only as an adventure really and so the
line in our book
is that um
human spaceflight
should not be pursued by nassau or
public funding agencies
because it has no practical
purpose
but also because
it's specially expensive if they do it
because
they would have to be risk averse
in launching civilians into space
i can illustrate that by noting that the
shuttle
was launched 135 times and it had two
spectacular failures
which each
killed the seven people in the crew
and
it had been mistakenly presented as safe
for civilians and there was a woman
school teacher killed in one of them it
was a big national trauma and they tried
to make it safer still um but
if you launch into space
just the kind of people prepared to
accept that sort of risk and of course
test pilots and people who go hang
gliding and
go to the south pole etc are prepared to
accept uh a two percent risk at least
for a big challenge then of course you
do it more cheaply and that's why um uh
i think um human space flies should be
left to the billionaires
um
and their sponsors um because then the
taxpayers aren't paying and they can
launch
simply those people who are prepared
to accept
high risks
space adventure not space tourism yeah
and and we should cheer them on um and
um
as regards where they would go
then um
low earth orbit i suspect can be done
quite cheaply in future but going to
mars
which is very very expensive and
dangerous for humans um the only people
who would go would be um these um
adventurers um maybe
on a one-way trip like some of the early
polar explorers and magellan and people
like that you know and we would cheer
them on um and
i
expect and i've ever hoped that by the
end of a century
there will be a small community
of such people on mars
um living they uncomfortably far less
comfortably than at the south pole or
the bottom of the ocean or the top of
everest but they will be there
and they won't have a
certain ticket um but they'll be there
um
incidentally i think it's a dangerous
delusion to think as uh elon musk
has said that we can have mass
emigration
from the earth to mars to escape the
earth's problems
it's a dangerous illusion because it's
far
easier to deal with climate change on
earth
than to terraform mars to make it
properly habitable to humans and so
there's no planet beef or risk-averse
people but for these crazy adventurers
then you can imagine that
they would be trying to live on mars as
um as great pioneers and by the end of
century
then there will be huge advances
compared to the present in two things
first in in understanding genetics
so is to genetically redesign one's
offspring
and secondly to uh use cyborg techniques
to
implant some something in our brain or
indeed think about downloading etc and
those techniques will
one hopes be heavily regulated on earth
on potentials
and ethical grounds and of course we are
pretty well adapted to the earth so we
don't have the incentive to do these
things in the way they were there so um
our argument is that um it'll be
those
crazy pioneers on mars
using all these
scientific advances which will be
controlled here
away from the regulators
they will
transition into a new post-human species
and so um if they do that and if they
transition into something which is
electronic
eventually because there may be some
limits to the capacity of flesh and
blood brains anyways um then um those
electronic entities um may not want to
stay on the planet like mars they may
want to go go away and so they'll be the
precursors of the future
um evolution of life and intelligence
coming from the earth
and of course there's one point which
perhaps astronomers are more aware of
than most people
most people are aware that we are the
outcome of four billion years of
evolution
most of them nonetheless probably think
that we humans
are somehow the culmination
the top of the tree
but yes
no astronomers can believe that because
astronomers know
that the earth
is four and a half billion years old
the sun has been shining for that length
of time but the sun has got six billion
years more to go before it flares up and
engulfs the inner planet so science
doesn't halfway through its life um and
uh the expanding universe
goes on far longer still maybe forever
and i like to quote woody allen who said
eternity is very long especially towards
the end uh so uh
so we shouldn't think of ourselves as
maybe even the halfway stage
in the emergence of uh cosmic complexity
and so these entities who are postcurses
they will go beyond the solar system and
of course even if there's nothing else
out there already
then they could
populate the rest of the galaxy
and maybe eventually meet the others who
are out there expanding as well yeah
expanding and populating yes with
expanded
uh capacity for life and intelligence
all those kinds of things well they
might um but um uh
again
all better off because i can't conceive
what they'd be like
they won't they won't be uh um
green
green men and women with eyes on stalks
you know maybe something quite different
um
we just don't know um but there is an
interesting question actually which
comes up when i've sometimes spoken to
audiences about this topic but the
question of consciousness and
self-awareness because you know going
back to philosophical questions i mean
whether an electronic robot
would uh be a zombie or would it be
conscious and self-aware
and um
i think there's no way of answering this
empirically
and
some people think that consciousness and
self-awareness is an emerging property
in any sufficiently complicated networks
and they would be others say well maybe
it's something special to the flesh and
blood that we're made of we don't know
um and
in a sense this may not matter um to the
way peop things behave because we
they could be zombies and still
behave as though they were intelligent
um but um i remember
after one of my talks someone came up
and said wouldn't it be sad
if
these future entities which were the
main intelligence universe um had no
self-awareness so there was nothing
which could appreciate the wonder and
mystery of the universe
and the beauty of the universe in the
way that we do
um and so it does perhaps affect one's
perspective of whether
you welcome or deplore
this possible future scenario depending
on whether you think the the future
post-human entities are
conscious and have an aesthetic sense or
whether they're just zombies
and uh of course you have to be humble
to realize that
self-awareness may not be the
highest form of being
that
humans have a very strong ego
and a very strong sense of identity
like personal identity connected to this
particular brain yeah uh it's not so
obvious to me that that is somehow
the
the highest achievement
of a life form
that maybe this kind of thing something
collective would be it's possible that
uh
well
i think from an alien perspective when
you look at earth
it's not so obvious to me that
individual humans are the atoms of
intelligence it could be the entire
organism together the collective
intelligence and so we humans think of
ourselves as individuals we dress up we
wear ties and suits and we give each
other prizes but in reality
the intelligence the things we create
that are beautiful emerges from our
interaction with each other and that may
be where the intelligence is ideas
jumping from one person to another over
generations yes but we have experiences
where we
can appreciate yes beauty and wonder and
all that and uh
a zombie may not have those experiences
yeah or it may have a very different
they do have a very
black and white harsh description of z
like a philosophical zombie zombie that
could be just a very different way to
experience
and you know
in terms of the explorers that colonize
mars
i
um i mean there's several things i want
to mention one
it's just at a high level to me that's
one of the most inspiring things humans
can do
is reach out into the unknown that's in
the space of ideas in the space of
science but also the explorers yes
and that
inspires people here on earth more
i mean it did
in their you know when going to the moon
or going out to space in the 20th
century that inspired a generation of
scientists
i think that also
could be used to inspire a generation of
new scientists in the 21st century by
reaching authors mars so
in that sense i think what elon musk and
others are doing is actually quite
inspiring it's not well i agree
it's not a recreational thing it's
actually has a deep humanitarian purpose
of really
inspiring the world
and then on the other one to push back
and your thought you know i don't think
elon says
we want to escape earth's problems
it's more that we should allocate some
small percentage of resources to have a
back-up plan
and because yes you yourself have spoken
about and written about
all the ways we clever humans could
destroy ourselves
and i'm not sure
it does seem when you look at the long
arc
of human history
it seems
almost obvious that we need to become a
multi-planetary species over a period if
we are to survive many centuries
it seems that
as we get clever and clever with the
ways we can destroy ourselves
earth is going to become less and less
safe
so in that sense
this is one of the things you know
people talk about climate change
and then we need to respond to climate
change and that's a long-term investment
we need to make but it's not really long
term it's a span of decades i think what
elon is doing is a really long-term
investment
we should be working on multi-planetary
colonization now if we were to have it
ready
five centuries from now and so taking
those early steps
and then also there's something happens
when you're caught when you
go into the unknown and do this really
difficult thing you discover something
very new you discover something about
robotics or materials engineering or
nutrition or neuroscience or human
relations or political systems that
actually work well with humans you
discover all those things and so it's a
it's worthy effort to go out there
and uh
try to become cyborgs
yeah no i agree with that i think the
only different point i'd make is that um
this is going to be very expensive
if it's done in a risk-averse way and
that's why i think we should be grateful
to uh the billionaires if they're going
to sort of foster um
these opportunities uh for uh
thrill-seeking uh risk-takers who we can
all admire yeah by the way i should push
back on the billionaires because there's
sometimes a negative connotation to the
world billionaire it's not a billionaire
it's a company versus government because
governments are billionaires and
trillionaires yeah it's not it's not the
wealth it's the the capitalist
uh imperative
so uh
which i think
deserves a lot more praise than people
are giving it
i'm i'm troubled by the sort of
criticism like it's billionaires playing
with toys
for their own pleasure
i think
what some of these companies like spacex
and blue origin are doing
is some of the most inspiring
engineering and even scientific work
ever done in human history no no i agree
i think the people who've made the
greatest wealth are people who've really
been mega benefactors i mean i think you
know
some of them some of you yeah yeah some
of them but but those who've
founded um
google and all that and uh and even
amazon they're
they're they're beneficiaries then
they're quite different category in my
view from those who just shuffle around
money um or or
or um or crypto coins and things like
that who are
now you're really talking trash yes
but
but i think
if they use their money in these ways
that's fine but but i think um it's true
that the far more money is owned by us
collectively as taxpayers but i think
the fact is it's in a democracy um
to be big resistance
to exposing human beings to very high
risks if in a sense we share
responsibility for it yeah i don't know
and that's that's the reason i think
it'll be done much more cheaply by
by these private funders that's an
interesting hypothesis but i have to
push back
i don't know if it's obvious why nasa
spends so much money
and takes such a long time
to develop the things he was doing so
before elon musk came along because i
would love i would love to live in a
world where government
actually uses taxpayer money to get some
of the best engineers and scientists in
the world and actually work across
governments russia china united states
european union together to do some of
these big projects it's strange that
elon is able to do this
much cheaper much faster
it could have to be do with risk
aversion you're right but i think it's
it's it's the uh
it's that it's that he had all the um uh
the whole assembly within this one
building as it were rather than
depending on a supply chain um but i
think it's also uh that he um had a
silicon valley culture and a younger
people whereas um the the big aerospace
companies boeing and lockheed martin um
they had people who were left over from
the apollo program in some cases and and
so they weren't quite quite so lively
and indeed um quite apart from the
controversial issues of the future of
human space flights um in terms of the
next generation of big rockets
then uh the one that uh musk is going to
launch for the first time this year
um the huge one um it's going to be far
far cheaper
than the one that nasa's been working on
at the same time um and that's because
it will have a reusable first stage
and it's going to be great it can launch
over 100 tons
into earth orbit
and instead that's going to be
make it feasible to do things that i
used to think were crazy like having
solar energy from space that's no longer
so crazy if you can do that
and also
for science because um its nose cone
could
contain within it
something uh as big as the entire
unfurled james webb telescope mirror
and therefore you can
have a big telescope much more cheaply
if you can launch it all in one piece
and so it's going to be hugely
beneficial to science and to any
practical use of space to have these
cheaper rockets that are far more
completely reusable than anyways nasa
had so i think mosques are a tremendous
service to the space exploration and the
whole space technology through these
rockets certainly
plus it's some big sexy rocket it's just
great engineering of course yeah it's
like looking at a beautiful big bridge
that humans are capable us descendants
of apes are capable to do something so
majestic yes uh and also the way they
land coming down on this bar that's
amazing it's both controls engineering
it's
um
increasing sort of intelligence in these
rockets but also
great propulsion engineering materials
uh enough in your ship and it just
inspires
it just inspires so many people no i'm
entirely with you on that yeah
so
would it be exciting to you to see a
human being step foot on mars in your
lifetime
yes i think it's unlikely in my lifetime
since i'm i'm so ancient but uh but i
think this this century is going to
happen and i think that that will indeed
be exciting and uh uh i hope there will
be a small community by the end of a
century but as as i say i think they
they may
go with one-way tickets or accepting the
risk of of uh of no return and so
they've got to be people like that and
uh i still think it's going to be
hard to persuade the public
to send people when you say straight out
that they may never come back
um but uh of course the apollo
astronauts they took a high risk and in
fact in in my um
previous book i i quote the
speech that's been written for nixon to
be read out if neil armstrong got stuck
on the moon and yeah
and he it was written by one of his um
his advisers um and very eloquent speech
you know
about
how they would have come to a noble end
etc um but of course there was a genuine
risk at that time um but
but
that
may have been accepted but
um clearly the
crashes of the shuttle
were not acceptable to the american
public
even when they were told that this was
only a two percent risk given how often
they launched it and so that's what
leads me to think that um
it's got to be left to the kind of
um people who are prepared to take these
risks and i think um uh think of america
eventually as a guy called steve fossett
who was uh um aviation did all kinds of
crazy things you know
and and then a guy who fell um
supersonically um
with the parachute from very held
altitude all these people we all cheer
them on they extend the bounds of
humanity um but uh
i don't think the public would be so
happy to fund them
i mean i disagree with that i think if
we change the narrative we should change
the story you think so i think i think
there's a lot of people
because the the the public is happy to
fund uh folks in other domains that take
bold giant risks first of all military
for example military i mean
obviously yes yes um i think this is in
the name of science especially if it's
sold correctly i sure as hell would go
up there with a risk would i i would
take a 40 percent chance risk of death
for something that's
i would i might want to be even older
than i am now
but then i would go i guess what i'm
trying to communicate is there's all
there's a lot of people on earth that's
the nice feature and i'm sure there's
going to be a significant percentage or
some percentage of people that are they
take on the risk for the adventure
so and i i particularly love that that
risk of adventure when taking on
inspires people and just the ripple
effect that has across the generation
especially among the young minds is uh
perhaps immeasurable
but
you're thinking um
that
sending humans
should be something we do less and less
sending humans to space that it should
be primarily an effort
the
the work of space exploration should be
done primarily by robots well i think it
it can be done much more cheaply
obviously on on mars and uh
no one's thinking of sending humans to
enceladus or europa
the outer planets um and uh
and the point is we'll have much better
uh robots because um
let's take an example um uh you see
these pictures of um
the moons of saturn and the picture of
pluto
and the comet taken by uh
probes and cassini spent 13 years
going around saturn and his moons after
seven year voyage and those are all
based on 1990s technology and if you
think of how smartphones have advanced
in 20 years since then does think how
much better one could do
instrumenting some very small
sophisticated probe and could send
dozens of them to explore the outer
planets and that's that's the way to do
that because no one thinks you could
send humans that far um and uh but i
would apply the same argument to
to uh mars
and if you want to assemble big
structures like um
for instance radio astronomers would
like to have a big radio telescope on
the far side of the moon so it's away
from the
earth's
background artificial radio waves um and
that could be
done by assembling
using robots without people so
on the moon and on mars
um i think
everything that's useful can be done by
machines much more cheaply than by
humans
do you know the movie 2001 a space
odyssey of course yes
uh you must be too young to see that
when he came out obviously uh yeah i
remember seeing when it came out
you saw when he came out
yeah yeah fifty years ago sixty what was
the 60 yeah it was in the 60s yeah
that's right
and still classic
it's still probably
i don't know
the greatest ai movie ever made yes yes
i agree one of the great space movies
ever made yes so
well let me ask you a philosophical
question since we're talking about
robots exploring space do you think hal
9000
is good
or bad so for people who haven't watched
this computer system makes a decision
[Music]
to uh
basically prioritize the mission that
the ship is on over the humans that are
part
of the mission um do you think hal is
good or evil
if you ask me probably in that context
it was probably good but i think you're
raising what is of course very much uh
active issue in everyday life
about
the extent to which we should um entrust
any important decision
uh to a machine and there again i'm very
worried because i think um if you are
recommended for an operation
or not given parole from prison
or even denied credit by your bank
you feel you
should be entitled to an explanation
it's not enough to be told that the
machine
has a more reliable record um on the
whole than humans have of making these
decisions you
think you should be given reasons you
could understand and and that's why i
think
the present societal trend
to um uh
take away the humans and uh leave us um
in the hands of decisions that we can't
contest uh is a very dangerous one i
think we've got to be very careful of
the extent to which ai which can handle
lots of information actually makes the
decisions without oversight and i think
we can
use them as a supplement
but to take the case of um uh
radiology and cancer um i mean it's true
that the
red
radiologist hasn't seen as many uh uh
x-rays of
cancer lungs as the machine so the
machine could certainly help but you
want the human to make the final
decision and i think that's true in most
of these instances but if we turn a bit
to the short-term
concerns with uh robotics i think the
the big worry of course is the
effect it has on um people's
self-respect and their labor market
and i think um
my solution would be
that we should um arrange to tax more
heavily
than big
international conglomerates which uh use
the robots um and
use that tax
to uh
fund
decently paid dignified posts
of the kind where being a human being is
important
above all carers for old people
teachers assistants for young gardeners
in public parks and things like that and
if the people who are now
working in mind-numbing jobs
in amazon warehouses uh or in
telephone call centers
are automated but those same people
are given
jobs where being a human is an asset
um then that's a plus plus situation and
so
that's
the way i think that we should
benefit from these these technologies um
take over the mind-numbing jobs
um and uh you use machines to make them
more efficient but um
enable um the people
so displaced to do jobs where we do want
a human being i mean most people when
they're when they're old um
the rich people if they have the choice
they want human carers and all that
don't they they may want have robots to
help with some things
empty bed pounds and things like that
but
but they they want real people and uh
and
certainly in this country i think even
worse in america um the the care of old
people
is completely inadequate and it needs us
more human beings to help them cope with
everyday life and look after them when
they're sick and um
and so
that seems to me the
way in which
the money raised in tax on these big
companies should be deployed so that's
in the short term but if you actually
just look the fact is where we are today
to
long-term future in a hundred years it
does seem that
there is some significant chance
that the human species is coming to an
end
in its
pure biological form
there's going to be greater and greater
integration to genetic modification than
a
cyborg type of creatures and so
you have to think all right well we're
going to have to get from here to there
and that process is going to be painful
and
that you know how there's so many
different trajectories that take us from
one place to another
it does seem that we need to deeply
respect
humanness and humanity
basic human rights
human welfare like happiness and
all that kind of no absolutely and
that's why i think we ought to try and
slow down the application of these human
enhancement techniques and cyborg
techniques for humans for just that
reason i mean uh
that's why i want to lead into the
people on mars let them do it but but uh
but
just not reason but they're people too
okay people mars are people too yeah i i
tend to you know but they are very
poorly adapted to where they are
right that's why they need spotification
whereas we're adapted
to the earth quite well so we don't need
these modifications we're we're happy to
be humans living in
in the environment where our ancestors
lived so we don't have the same same
motive so i think there's a difference
but i agree with it we don't want uh
drastic changes probably in in our
lifestyle um and
that indeed is a worry because some
things are changing so fast um but i
think um i'd like to inject a note of
caution um
if you think of the way uh progress in
one technology goes um it goes in a sort
of spurt it goes up very fast and then
it levels off um let me give you
two examples well the one we've had
already a human space flight
at the time of the apollo program which
was only 12 years after
sputnik won um i i was alive then and i
thought it would only be 10 or 20 years
further before there were footprints on
mars but as we know for reasons we could
all understand um
that was and still remains the high
point of human space exploration um
that's because it was funded for
reason of superpower rivalry issues
public expense um but uh let me give you
an another case um
civil aviation um if you think of the
change between uh 1919 when that was all
[ __ ] and brown's first transatlantic
fight to 1979 the first flight of the
jumbo jet was a big change
but it's more than 50 years since 1969
and we still have jumbo just more or
less the same so that's an example of
something which developed fast and
change ever and to take another analogy
um we've had huge developments in uh
mobile phones but uh i suspect the
iphone the iphone 24 may not be too
different from the iphone 13.
um because you know
they
develop but then
they saturate and then maybe some new
innovation takes over in stimulating
economic growth
yeah so it's that
we have to be cautious about being too
optimistic
and we have to be cautious about being
too cynical i think that is well
optimistic is begging the question i
mean do we want this very rapid change
right so first of all there's some
degree to which technological
advancement is is something is a force
that can't be stopped and so the
question is about directing it versus
stopping it
can be sort of
slow we'll take human space flight there
could be have been
footprints on mars if um if america had
gone on spending four percent of the
federal budget
on the project after
yes upon uh
the reason
there were very good reasons but um
and we could we could have had
supersonic flight but concorde came and
went during the 50 years
but the reason
it didn't progress it's not because
we realize it's not good for human
society the reason it didn't progress is
because it could make uh
sort of from a capitalist perspective it
couldn't make
uh there there was no short-term or
long-term way for it to make money so
for me
but that's the same as saying it's not
good for society
i don't think
everything that makes money is good for
society and everything that doesn't make
money is bad for society right that's a
that's a difficult
that's a difficult thing we're always
contending with when we look at social
networks it's not obvious even though
they make a tremendous amount of money
that they're good for society especially
how they're currently implemented with
advertisement and engagement
maximization
so that's the constant struggle
you know i agree with you as many
innovations are damaging yes yeah
yes uh well
but i would have thought that supersonic
flight was
uh something that would benefit only a
tiny elite sure huge expense and
environmental damage that was obviously
something which they're very glad not to
have in my opinion
yeah
but perhaps there was a way to do it
where it could benefit the general
populace if you were to think about
airplanes wouldn't you think that in the
early days airplanes would have been
seen as something that can surely only
benefit
one percent at most of the population as
opposed to a much larger percentage
there's there's another aspect of
capital a system that's able to drive
down cost once you get the thing kind of
going so the you know we get together
maybe with taxpayer money and get the
thing going at first and once it gets
going companies step up and drive down
the cost and actually make it so that
blue collar folks can actually start
using the stuff yeah sometimes that does
happen that's good
yeah so it's that's again the the
double-edged sword of human civilization
that
some technology hurts us some benefits
us and we don't know ahead of time we
can just do our best and
there's a gap between what could be done
and what
we can actually decide to do
yes in the term you could push forward
some developments um
faster than we do let me ask you
in your book on the future prospects for
humanity
you imagine a time machine that allows
you to send a tweet-length message to
scientists in the past like to newton
yes um what tweet would you send
it's an interesting thought experiment
what message would you send to newton
about what we know today
well i think he'd love to know that
there were planets around other stars um
he'd like to know that that would really
blow his mind he'd like to know that
everything was made of atoms
uh he'd like to know that if he looked a
bit more carefully through his prisms
and
looked at light not just from the sun
but from
from some flames he might get the idea
that uh different substances emitted
light of different different colors and
he might have
been
twigged to discover some things that had
to wait two or three hundred years
could have given him those clues i think
it's kind of it's fascinating to think
to look back at how little
he understood
people at that time understood about our
world
yes
and certainly about the cosmos because
of both
well if you think about astronomy um
then until about 1850
um uh astronomy was a matter of um um uh
the positions of how the stars
and the planets moved around etc of
course that goes back a long way but
newton understood why the planets moved
around in ellipses but uh he didn't
understand um
why the solar system was all in a plane
what we call the ecliptic
and uh he didn't understand it no one
did till the mid 19th century
what the stars are made of i mean they
were thought to be made of some fifth
essence not earth earth and water like
everything else you know um and it was
only after 1850
when um people did use prisms more
precisely to get to get spectra that
they realized that the the sun was made
of the same stuff as the earth and
indeed the stars were
and uh it wasn't till
um 1930 the people
knew about nuclear energy and knew what
kept the sun shining for for so long so
it was quite late that some of these key
ideas
came in you know which would have
completely transformed newton's views
and of course the
entire scale of the solar of the galaxy
and
and the rest of the universe just
imagine this came later what he would
have thought about the big bang or even
just general relativity absolutely
gravity yeah just just
him and einstein talking for for a
couple of weeks
[Music]
would he be able to make sense of
space-time and the curvature of
space-time and well i think
given a quick course i mean he was sort
of uh if it looks back he he was really
a unique intellect in a way you know and
uh
he said that he
thought better than everything everyone
else by thinking on things continually
and thinking very deep thoughts and um
so he was a utterly remarkable intellect
obviously but of course scientists
aren't all like that i think it's the
one thing that interests me having spent
a life among scientists is what a
variety of uh mindsets and mental styles
they have yes um and um um
well
just to contrast newton and darwin um
darwin uh uh said uh uh and he felt
correct as he
that he thought he just had a um as much
sort of a
common sense and reasoning power is the
average lawyer
and that's probably true because his
ability was to sort of uh collect data
and think through things deeply um
that's a quite different kind of
thinking from what was involved in a in
newton or someone doing abstract
mathematics
i think in the 20th century the coolest
well there's the theory but
from a astronomy perspective
black holes
is one of the most
fascinating entities to have been
through theory and through experiment to
have emerged from obviously i agree it's
an amazing story that uh um
well of course
what's interesting is einstein's
reaction because of course although as
you know we now accept this as one of
the most remarkable predictions of
einstein's theory uh he never took it
seriously even believed it um although
it was a consequence of uh
seuss of his equations which someone
discovered
just a year after his theory
schwarzschild um but he never took it
seriously and others did but then of
course
well this is something that i've been
involved in actually finding evidence
for black holes and that's coming last
50 years and um
so now there's pretty compelling
evidence that they exist
um as the remnants of stars or big ones
in the centers of galaxies and beyond we
understand uh
what's the what's going on we have ideas
vaguely how they form
and of course uh
gravitational waves have been detected
and that's an amazing piece of
technology ligo is one of the most
incredible engineering efforts of all
time that's an example where the
engineers deserve the most of the credit
because the precision is well as they
said it's like
measuring the thickness of a hair at the
distance of alpha centauri yeah it's
incredible 10 to the minus 21. so maybe
actually if we step back what are black
holes what do we humans understand about
black holes and what's still
unknown einstein's theory extended by
people like roger penrose tells us that
um black holes are in a sense rather
simple things basically because they are
solutions of einstein's equations
and the thing that was shown in the
1960s by roger penrose in particular
um and by a few other people was that um
a black hole when it forms and settles
down
is defined just by two quantities it's
mass and it's spin
so they're actually
based standardized objects it's amazing
those objects are standardized as that
um can be so big and can lurk in the
vessel solar system and so
that's the situation for a really formed
black hole but the way they form
obviously is very messy and complicated
and
one of the things that i've worked on a
lot is
what the phenomena are
which are best attributed to black holes
and what may lead to them and all that
and um uh which can you explain to that
so what what what are the different
phenomena that lead to a black hole okay
let's let's talk about it this is okay
well that's so cool yes okay okay
well i mean i think one thing that
only became understood really in the
1950s i suppose and beyond was
how stars evolve differently depending
on how heavy they are yeah this the sun
um burns highs into helium and then when
it's run out of that it contracts to be
a white dwarf and we know how long that
will take to take about 10 billion years
altogether for its lifetime but big
stars
burn up their fuel more quickly
and more interestingly because when
they've turned highs into helium
they then get even hotter so they can
fuse helium into carbon and go up the
periodic table
and then they eventually explode
when they have an energy crisis and they
blow out that process material which as
a digression is crucially important
because um all the atoms inside our
bodies
were synthesized inside a star
a star that lived and died more than
five billion years ago before our
services and formed and so we each have
inside us atoms made in thousands of
different stars all over the milky way
and that's an amazing idea in my
predecessor fred hoyle in 1946 was the
first person to suggest that idea and
that's been borne out that's a wonderful
idea
so
that's how massive stars explode and
they leave behind
something which
is very exotic and of two kinds one
possibility is a neutron star and these
were first discovered in 1967
68. um these are stars a bit heavier
than the sun
uh which are compressed to an amazing
density so the whole mass of more than
the sun's mass is in something about 10
miles across
so
they're extraordinarily dense
the exotic physics
and
and they they've
they've been studied in immense detail
and they've been real laboratories
because the good thing about astronomy
apart from
exploring what's out there is to use the
fact that the cosmos has provided us
with a lab with far more extreme
conditions that we could ever simulate
and so we learned lots of basic physics
from looking at these objects um and
that's been true neutrons but for black
holes
that's even more true because the um
bigger stars
when they collapse they
leave something
behind in the center which is too big to
be a stable by two or four neutron star
becomes a black hole
and we know that there are lots of black
holes weighing about
10 or up to 50 times as much as the sun
which are the remnants of stars they
were detected first 50 years ago
when a black hole was orbiting around
another star
and grabbing material from the other
star which swirled into it and gave us
x-rays so the x-rays astronomers found
these um
objects orbiting around an ordinary star
and emitting x-ray radiation very
intensely
varying on the baseball time scale so
something very small and dense was
giving that radiation that was the first
evidence for black holes but then the
other thing that happened was realizing
that there was a
different class of monster black holes
in the center of galaxies
and um
these are responsible what's called
quasars which is when uh
something in the center of a galaxy
is grabbing some fuel and outshines all
the
100 billion stars or so in the rest of
the galaxy giant beam
yeah
white and in many cases it should be it
should be it should be
is that
yeah that's got to be the most epic
thing the universe produces is quasars
um well it's a it's a debate about the
most epic but uh
quasars maybe or maybe gamma ray bursts
or something but but they're they are
remarkable and they were a mystery for a
long time and there weren't things i
worked on in my
younger days so even though they're so
bright they're still a mystery and but
well i wouldn't say i can only see them
they're a little mystery now i think we
do understand basically what's going on
how were quasars discovered
well they were discovered when
astronomers found things that looked
like stars and that they were small
enough to be a point-like and not
resolved by a telescope but uh uh
outshone an entire galaxy
yeah and uh that is suspicious yes
but uh
which you now know are black holes
and they were um
black holes were capturing gas
and that gas was getting very hot but it
was producing um
far more energy than all the stars added
together and it was the energy of the
black hole
that was um lighting up all the gas in
the galaxy so you've got a spectrum of
it
there so so
this was something which was realized
from the 1970s onwards
and uh as you say the other thing we've
learned is that they often do produce
these jets squirting out um which could
be detected in in all wave bands so um
there's now a standard picture yeah
black hole generating jets of light yeah
the center of most
galaxies yes that's right do we know
do you ever sense if every galaxy has
one of these big
big boys
big black holes most galaxies have big
black holes they vary in size the one in
our
galactic center do we know much about
ours
we we do yes we um we know um uh it
weighs about as much as four million
suns
uh which is less than some is there
several billion in other galaxies um and
but we know this um the one narcotic
center isn't
very bright or conspicuous and that's
because not much is falling into it at
the moment if if a black hole is
isolated then of course it doesn't
radiate it only
all that radiates is gas
swirling into it
which is very hot or has magnetic space
it's only radiating the thing it's
murdering or consuming right or however
you put it yeah that's right and so so
um it's thought that our galaxy may have
been bright bright at some time in the
past but now uh and that's when the
black hole formed or grew um but but now
it's uh not um capturing very much gas
and so it's it's rather it's one of the
faints and only detected indirectly and
by fairly weak radio mission and uh and
so i think the answer to your question
is that um
we suspect that most galaxies have a
black hole in them
so that means at some stage in their
lives
or maybe one or more stages they went
through a phase of being like a quasar
where that black hole um captured gas
and became very very bright
but for the rest of their the lives the
black holes are fairly questioned
because there's not much gas
falling into them
and so this universe of ours is
sprinkled a bunch of galaxies and giant
black holes it was
like
very large number of stars
uh orbiting these black holes and then
planets orbiting
likely it seems like
planets orbiting almost every one of
those stars
and just this beautiful universe of ours
well what happens when galaxies collide
when these two big black holes
collide is that
is
well um what would happen is that uh
well and i should say that um this is
going to happen near us one day but not
for four billion years because the
andromeda galaxy which is the biggest
galaxy
near to us which is about
three million light years away which is
a big disc galaxy with a black hole is
hub rather like our milky way and um
that's uh um in
falling towards us because they're both
in a common gravitational potential well
and um
that will collide with our galaxy in
about four billion years but it'll be
it'll
be
maybe it'll be less a collision and more
of a dance because it'll be like a
swirling situation
but eventually it'll be to be a merger
they'll go through each other and then
merge in fact uh um the nice movies to
be made of this you know computer
simulations yes and it'll go through um
and um
and then um
there's a black hole in the sense of
andromeda and our galaxy and the galax
the black holes will uh
settle towards the center yes then they
will orbit around each other very fast
and then they will eventually merge
and that will produce a big burst of
gravitational waves yes um very big
burst that an alien civilization with a
ligo-like detector would be able to
detect
yes well in fact we will but we can
detect these with them
they're lower frequencies than the uh
the waves that have been detected by
ligo so there's a space interferometer
which can detect these they're about
it's about one cycle per hour rather
than about a hundred cycles per second
yes it's the ones that detect it um but
that that would happen but um uh
thinking back to what will happen in
four billion years to uh any of our
descendants they'll be okay because the
um
the the two disc galaxies were merged
it'll end up as a sort of amorphous
elliptical galaxy but um the stars won't
be much closer together than they are
now
it'll it'll still be
just twice as many stars in the
structure almost as big and so um
the chance of another star colliding
with our sun would still be very small
and yeah because there's actually a lot
of space between indeed stars and
planets yes the chance of a star getting
close enough to affect our solar
system's orbit it's small and it won't
change that very much so
we could be reassured a heck of a starry
sky though
what would that look well it won't make
much difference even to that actually
it'll just be um
wouldn't that look kind of beautiful
when you're swirling or is oh because
it's scrolling so slowly yeah
but they're far away so we just retwise
as many stars in the sky yeah and but
the pattern changes
yeah the pattern will change a bit and
uh there won't be the milky way because
the milky way uh
across the sky is because we are looking
in the disk of our galaxy and you lose
that
because the um the disc will be so
disrupted and uh it will be more so the
spherical distribution and of course
many galaxies are like that um and
that's probably because they have been
through mergers of this kind if we
survive four billion years we would
likely be able to survive beyond that oh
yeah
what what's the other thing on the
horizon for humans uh in terms of the
sun burning out all those kinds of
interesting cosmological
threats to our
civilization well i think
on the
cosmological times together because it
won't be humans because uh
something else even if evolution has
gone no faster than darwinian and i
would like it will be fast and darwin in
the future uh then um we're thinking
about
six billion years before the sun dies so
any entities watching the death of the
sun if they're still around maybe it's
different much as we are from slime mold
or something you know
and uh far more different still if they
become electronic so on that time scale
we just can't predict anything but i
think going back to um
uh to the human time scale um then um uh
we've talked about
whether there'll be people on mars by
the end of a century
and uh even in these long perspectives
then
indeed this century is very special
because it may see the transition
between purely flesh and blood entities
to those which are sort of cyborgs and
that'll be a an important transition in
um
in in
biology and complexity
in this century but of course the other
importance and this has been the theme
of a couple of my older books is that um
this is the first century when one
species
namely our species
has the future of the planet in his
hands
and that's because of
two types of
concerns
one is that there are more of us
we're more demanding of energy and
resources and therefore we are for the
first time
changing the whole planet
through um um climate change loss of
biodiversity and all those issues this
has never happened in the past because
having enough humans have been much in
power so this is a um
an effect that's obviously is high in
everyone's agenda now and rightly so
because um
we've got to ensure that we leave a
heritage that isn't eroded or damaged to
future generations um and so that's one
class of threats but there's another
thing that worries me
perhaps more than many people seem to
worry and that's the
threat of misuse of technology
and so this is particularly because um
technologies
empower even small groups
of uh malevolent people or
indeed even careless people
to create
some effect which could cascade globally
and um
to take an example um a uh a dangerous
pathogen or pandemic
um i mean my worst nightmare is that
there could be
some
small group that uh can engineer a
virus to make it more virulent or more
transmissible than the natural virus
this is so called gain of function
experiments which were done on the flu
virus 10 years ago and can be done for
others
and of course we now know from covet 19
that um
our world is so interconnected
that a disaster in one part of the world
can't be confined to that path and was
spread globally so it's possible for a
few dissidents with expertise in biotech
could create a global catastrophe of
that kind and also i think um
we need to worry about very large scale
disruption by cyber attacks in fact um i
quote in
one of my books a 2012 report from the
american pentagon
about the um possibility of a state
level cyber attack on the electricity
grid in the eastern united states
which is it could happen and it says at
the end of this chapter that this would
merit the nuclear response
it's a pretty scary possibility that was
10 years ago
and i think now
what would have needed a state actor
then
could be done perhaps by a small group
empowered by ai and so there's obviously
been a
an arms race between the uh um the cyber
criminals and the cyber security people
luckily which side is winning but the
main point is that as we become
more dependent on more
integrated systems
uh we could get more vulnerable and uh
um
and and so we have the knowledge
then the misuse of that knowledge
becomes um uh more and more of a threat
and i say bio and cyber are the the two
biggest concerns um and uh if we depend
too much on ai and complex systems then
um just breakdowns it may be that they
they break down and um um even if it's
an innocent breakdown then maybe pretty
hard to mend it and just think how much
worse the pandemic would have been
if we'd lost the internet in the middle
of it
and it would be dependent more than ever
for communication everything else on on
on the internet and zooms and all that
um and if that had broken down that
would have made things far worse and
those are the kinds of
threats that we i think need to be more
energized and politicians need to be
more energized um to uh minimize and um
one of the things i've been doing the
last year um through being a member of
our part of our parliament is sort of um
i have to instigate a committee to think
more on better preparedness for
extreme technological risks and things
like that so they're a big concern in my
my mind that uh we've got to make sure
that we um can benefit from these um
advances um but safely because
the states are getting higher you know
the benefits are getting great as we
know huge benefits from computers but
but also huge downsides as well
and one of the things this war
in ukraine has shown
one of the most terrifying things
outside of the humanitarian crisis
is that at least for me i realized
that the human capacity to initiate
nuclear war
is
greater than i thought
i thought the lessons of the past have
been learned
it seems that we hang on the brink of
nuclear war
with this conflict like every single day
with just one
mistake
or bad actor
or
the actual leaders of the particular
nations launching a nuclear strike and
all hell broke breaks loose
so then
adding to that picture cyber attacks and
so on that can
lead to to confusion and chaos and then
out of that confusion
um
calculations are made such that uh a
nuclear launch is
a nuclear weapon is launched and it's
and then you're talking about
i mean i don't it directs probably 60 70
percent
of humans on earth are dead instantly
and then the rest
i mean it's uh basically 99 percent of
the human population is wiped out in the
period of well five years that's that
was real devastation for civilization of
course and of course we're quite right
that this could happen very quickly um
because of uh um
you know
information coming in and there's a
there's hardly enough time for human
um collected and
careful thought and there had have been
uh recorded cases of false alarms
several where um
where there have been suspected um
attacks from the other side and
fortunately they've been realized to be
false alarm soon enough but but this
could happen and there's a new class of
threats actually which
in our center in cambridge people are
thinking about which is that um
the commander control system
of
the nuclear
weapons and the submarine fleet and all
that um is now more automated and uh
could be subject to cyber attacks and
that's a new threat which didn't exist
um 30 years ago and so um i think
indeed it it's it's we're in a sort of
scary world i think
and uh
it's because things happen faster
and human beings aren't in such direct
and immediate control because someone is
delegated to machines um and also
because the world is so much more
interconnected
then
some
local event can cascade globally
in a way it never could in the past and
much faster
yeah it's a double-edged sword because
the interco interconnectedness
brings
brings a higher quality of life across a
lot of metrics yeah it can do but of
course there again i mean if you think
of supply chains where we get stuff from
around the world and um one lesson we've
learned is that there's a trade-off
between resilience and efficiency and
it's resilient
to have
an inventory in stock and to depend on
local supplies where it's more efficient
to have
a long supply chain
but the
risk there is that a
break in one link in one chain
can screw up car production this has
already happened in the pandemic so so
there's a trade-off and there are
examples i mean for instance the other
thing we learned was that uh it may be
efficient to have 95 percent of your
hospital intensive care beds occupied
all the time which would be in the uk
situation whereas to do what the germans
do and always keep 20 of them free for
an emergency is really a sense of a
precaution and so i think um
we've probably learned a lot of lessons
from kobit 19 and they would include um
rebalancing the trade-off between
resilience
and efficiency
boy the the fact that coven 19 a
pandemic that could have been a lot a
lot worse
brought the world to its knees anyway
it could be far worse in terms of its uh
fatality rate or fatality right yeah
so the fact that that i mean it revealed
so many flaws in our human institutions
yeah yeah
yes and i think you know i'm rather
pessimistic because um
uh i do worry about the uh
the
bad actual a small group who can produce
catastrophe um and um uh uh if you
imagine someone
with access to the kind of equipment
that's available in university labs or
industrial labs and they could create
some dangerous pathogen um then even one
such person is too many
and how can we stop that because uh
it's true that you can
have regulations i mean academies are
having meetings etc about
how to regulate these new biological
experiments etc make them safe but even
if you have all these regulations
then enforcing regulations
is yeah pretty hopeless we can't enforce
the tax laws globally we can't enforce
the drug laws globally and so similarly
we can't readily enforce the um
laws against people doing these danish
experiments
even if all the governments say they
should be prohibited and so my my line
on this is that
uh
all nations are going to face a big
trade-off between three things we value
um
freedom
security and privacy
and i think uh um
different nations will
uh make that choice differently um the
chinese
would give a
privacy and have more certainly more
security if not more liberty um but i
think uh um
in
in our countries um i think we're going
to have to give up more privacy
in the same way that's a really
interesting trade-off um but
there's also something about human
nature here where
i personally believe that all humans are
capable of good and evil
and there's some aspect to which we can
fight
this by encouraging
people
incentivizing people towards the better
angels of their nature
so
in order for a small group of people to
create to engineer deadly pathogens
you have to have people
that for whatever
trajectory took them in life wanting to
do that kind of thing and if we can
aggressively
work on a world that sort of sees the
beauty
in everybody and encourages
the flourishing of everybody in terms of
mental health in terms of meaning in
terms of all those kinds of things
that's one way to fight the development
of um
of weapons that can lead to atrocities
yes and i completely agree with that and
to reduce the reason why people feel
embittered yes
but of course we've got a long way to go
to do that because uh if you look at the
present world
um nearly everyone in africa
has reason to feel embittered because um
uh their economic development is lagging
behind most of the rest of the world and
the prospects of getting out of uh the
poverty trap is
is rather bleak especially if the
population grows because for instance um
they can't develop like the eastern
tigers by cheap manufacturing because
robots are taking that over uh so that
they will naturally feel embittered um
by the inequality and of course um what
we need to have is some sort of
mega version of the marshall plan that
helped europe in the post-world war ii
era um to enable africa to develop that
would be um not just an altruistic thing
for europe to do but in our interest
because otherwise
those in africa will feel massively
disaffected um and indeed um it's a
manifestation of the excessive
inequalities the fact that the 2000
richest people in the world
have enough money to double the income
of the bottom billion
and uh and that's uh um you know an
indictment of the ethics of the world
and this is where i've ha
my friend stephen pinker and i have had
some contact we wrote joint articles on
bio threats and all that um but um he
writes these books being very optimistic
about quoting figures about how uh um
life expectancy has gone up infamous has
gone down literacy has gone up with all
those things and he's quite right about
that um and so he says the world's
getting getting better and
do you disagree with your friend steve
pinker
well i mean i i i agree with those facts
okay but i think he misses out he misses
out part of the picture and because um
there's a new class of threats
which uh um hang over us now which
didn't hangovers in the past and i would
also question whether we have
collectively
improved our ethics at all because um
let's think back to the middle ages it's
true that as pinker says the average
person was uh
in a more miserable state than they are
today on average um for all the reasons
he quantifies that's that's fine um but
in the middle ages there wasn't very
much
that could have been done to improve
people's
lot in life because of lack of knowledge
and lack of science etc um so the gap
between the way the world was
which is pretty miserable and the way
the world could have been
which wasn't all that much better it was
fairly narrow
whereas now
the gap between the way the world is and
the way the world could be
is far far wider
and therefore i think we are ethically
um
more uh um at fault
uh in allowing this gap to get wider
than it was in medieval times and so i i
would very much question and dispute the
idea that we are um ethically um in
advance of our predecessors that's
collectively a lot of interesting
hypotheses in there and i don't
they're it's a it's a fascinating
question of how much
is the size of that gap between the way
the world is and the way the world could
be is a reflection of our ethics or
maybe sometimes it's just a reflection
of a very large number of people
uh like maybe it's a a technical
challenge too it's not just well about
political systems political systems like
how many
and we're trying to figure this thing
out like there's 20th century
tried this thing that sounded really
good on paper
of collective the communism type of
things
and it's like turned out at least the
way that was done there
at least atrocities and the suffering
and the murder of tens of millions of
people okay so that didn't work let's
try democracy
and that seems to have a lot of flaws
but it seems to be the best thing we've
got so far so we're trying to figure
this out as our technologies become more
and more powerful have the capacity to
do a lot of good to the world but also
unfortunately have the capacity to
destroy the entirety of the human
civilization and i think it's social
media generally
which
makes it
harder to get a
a sort of moderate consensus because in
the old days when people got their
news
filtered through responsible journalists
in this country the bbc and they made
newspapers etc and they would muffle the
crazy extremes whereas now of course um
they're there on the internet and if you
click on them you get to understand more
extreme and so i think we are
seeing a sort of dangerous polarization
which i think is going to make all
countries harder to govern and not
something we found pessimistic about so
to push back it is true that brilliant
people like you highlighting the
limitations of social media
is making them realize
the
the stakes and the failings of social
media companies but the same time
they're reviewing the division
it's not like they're creating it
they're revealing it in part
and so that puts a lot of
uh
that puts the responsibility into the
hands of social media and the
opportunity in the hands of social media
to alleviate some of that division so it
could in the long arc of human history
result so bringing some of those
divisions and the anger and the hatred
to the surface so that we can talk about
it and as opposed to disproportionately
promoting it actually just surfacing it
so we can get over well you're assuming
that the uh the fat cats are more public
spiritual than the politicians and i'm
not sure about that
i think there's a lot of money to be
made in being
publicly spirited i think there's a lot
of money to be made in increasing the
amount of love in the world despite the
sort of public perception
that
all
the social media companies heads are
interested in doing is making money
i think
that may be true but i just personally
believe people being happy
is a hell of a good business model
and so making
as many people happy
helping them flourish in a long-term way
that's a lot of way to make people
that's a good way to make well i think
on the other hand i think guilt and
shame are good motives to make you
behave better in future okay so that's
my experience
[Laughter]
from maybe in the political perspective
of certainness in case yeah but it does
make sense now that we can destroy
ourselves with nuclear weapons with
engineered pandemics and so on
that the aliens would show up
that
like if i was
the
um you know had a leadership position
maybe as a scientist or otherwise in an
alien civilization
and i would come upon earth
i would try to watch from a distance
do not interfere
and i would start interfering
when these life forms start becoming
quite they have the capacity to be
destructive
and so
i mean it's a it is an interesting
question when people talk about your
full sightings on all those kinds of
things
that at least these are benign aliens
you're thinking
benign yes i mean they
benign almost curious almost
partially as with all curiosity
partially selfish to try to observe is
there something interesting about this
particular evolutionary system
um because i'm sure even to aliens earth
is a curiosity yeah
but it's in this very special
stage
in this question especially perhaps this
century is very special yes among the 45
million centuries the earth experienced
already so it is a very special time
where they should be especially
interested but um i think
going back to the um the politics and
the other problem is uh getting
people who have short-term concerns to
care about the long term by the long
term i now mean just looking 30 or 30
years or so ahead
you know i know people who've been
scientific advisors to governments and
things and
they may make these points but of course
they don't have much traction because as
we know very well
any politician has an urgent agenda of
very worrying things to deal with and so
um they aren't going to prioritize
these issues which are um longer longer
term and less immediate and don't just
concern their constituents if they
concern distant parts of the world um
and so i i think i think um what what we
have to do is to um
enlist
charismatic individuals
to convert the public because if the if
the politicians know the public care
about something
climate change as an example um then uh
they will
make decisions which
take cognizance of that
and i think for that to happen
then we do need some um
public individuals who are respected
by everyone
and to have a high profile and in the
climate context
well i i i would say that i mentioned
four very desperate people who've had
such a big effect in the last few years
one is pope francis there's david
attenborough he does bill gates and the
others greater thornburg and those four
people have certainly had a big shift in
public opinion
um and uh uh
and even changed the rhetoric of
business although how deep that is i
don't know and so yeah but
but politicians um
can't let these issues drop down off the
agenda um if if there's a public clamor
and it needs people like that to keep
the public clamor going to push back a
little bit so those four are very
interesting and i have deep respect for
them they have
except david anderbaugh uh david
anderson really i mean everybody loves
him i mean i can't say anything but the
you know with bill gates and greta there
there is that that also has created a
lot of division oh sure
and this is a big problem so it's not
just charismatic
i i put that responsibility actually in
the scientific community and pope does
too yeah yep uh and the politicians so
we need
the
charismatic leaders
and they're rare yeah when you look at
human history
those are the ones that make a
difference those are the ones that
um not the ride
they they inspire
the populace to think long term
the jfk we do
we'll go to the moon in this decade not
because it's easy but because it is hard
there's no discussion about
like um
short-term political gains or any of
that kind of stuff uh in in the vision
of going to the moon
or going to mars or taking on gigantic
uh
projects or taking on world hunger or
taking on climate change or
uh the education system all those things
that require long-term significant
investment that that
it's hard to find those people and yeah
and incidentally i think another problem
is
which is a downside of social media is
that um
of younger people i know
um the number who would contemplate a
political career
has gone down because of the the
pressures
on them and their family from social
media um it's a hell of a job now um and
so i think we are all losers because the
quality of people who choose that
path
is um
is really
dropping and as we see by the quality of
those who are in these compositions that
said i think
the silver lining there is the quality
of the competition
actually is inspiring
because it's it's it shows to you that
there's a dire need of leaders which i
think would be inspiring to young people
to step into the yeah
i mean great leaders are not afraid of a
little bit of a little bit of uh fire on
social media so if you have you have a
20 year old kid now a 25 year old kid
is seeing how the world just been
responded to the pandemic seeing the
geopolitical division over the war in
ukraine seeing the brewing war between
the west and china
we need great leaders and there's a
hunger for them and the time will come
when when when they step up i i
i
i believe that but also to add to your
list of four
he doesn't get enough credit i've been
defending him in this conversation elon
musk in terms of the fight and climate
change
uh but he also has led to a lot of
division but we we need more david
attenborough yeah no no i mean i i'm a
fan
therefore i mean i've heard him
described as the 21st century brunel for
his innovation and that's true but uh um
whether he's uh an ethical inspiration i
don't know
yeah he has a a lot of fun on twitter
well let me ask you
to put on your
wise sage hat
what advice would you give to young
people today
maybe
they're teenagers in high school maybe
early college
uh what advice would you give
to a career or have a life they can be
proud of yes
well i'd be very difficult really um
about offering any any wisdom but uh
i think
i think
they they should
they should realize that um uh um
the choices
they make
at that time are um important and um
from the experience of
i've had and with many friends um many
people don't realize that opportunities
open
until it's too late
they somehow think that some
opportunities are only open to a few
privileged people
and they don't even try and then that
they could succeed um but um
if i focus on people
working in um
some profession i know about like
science i would say
pick an area to work in
where new things are happening
uh where uh you can
do something that the old guys never had
a chance to think about
don't go into a field that's fairly
stagnant because then um there will be
much to do or you'll be trying to tackle
the problems that the old guys got stuck
on and so i think in science um i can
give people good advice that they should
um pick a subject where there are
exciting new developments and also of
course something which uh suits their
style because even within science which
is just one profession um there's a big
range of style between the sort of
solution thinker the person does field
work the person who works in a big team
etc and whether you like computing or
mathematical thought etc so pick some
subject that suits your style and where
things are happening fast um and uh be
prepared to be flexible that's what i'd
say really keep your eyes open for the
opportunity throughout like you said go
to a new field go to a field where new
cool stuff is happening yeah just keep
your eyes open yeah that's passive
students but i think most of us and i
include myself in this didn't realize
this sort of thing as too late
yeah i think this applies way beyond
science
what do you make of this finiteness of
our life do you think about death do you
think about mortality do you think about
your mortality and are you afraid of
death well i mean i'm not afraid because
i i think i'm lucky i feel lucky to have
lots as long as i have
um and
and to have been fairly lucky in um
in my life in many respects compared to
to most people so i feel very fortunate
um
this reminds me of this
current uh
emphasis on uh living much longer than
the so-called altos laboratories
which have been set up by
billionaires
there's one in
san francisco one in
la jolla i think and one in cambridge
and uh
they're funded by um these guys who when
young wanted to be rich and now they're
rich they want to be young again they
won't find that quite so easy and do we
want this i don't know if
if there was um some
elite that was able to do much longer
than others that would be a really
fundamental kind of inequality and um
i think um
if it happened to everyone
then that might be an improvement it's
not so obvious um but uh
i i think um
for my my part i think to have uh lived
as as long as most people
and had a fortunate life is all i can
expect and a lot to be grateful for
those are all flash issues well
i am incredibly honored that you sit
down with me today i thank you so much
for life
of exploring some of the deepest
mysteries of our universe and um of our
humanity and thinking about our future
with existential risks that are before
us
um it's it's a huge honor martin that
you sit with me and i really enjoyed it
and well thank you lex i thought we
couldn't go on for as long as this but
we could have gone much longer
exactly thank you so much
thank you for listening to this
conversation with martin reece to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words from
martin ruiz himself
i'd like to widen people's awareness of
the tremendous time span lying ahead for
our planet and for life itself
most educated people are aware
there were the outcome of nearly 4
billion years of darwinian selection
but
many tend to think that humans are
somehow the common nation
our son however is less than halfway
through its lifespan
it will not be humans who watch the
sun's demise
six billion years from now
any creatures that then exist will be as
different from us as we are from
bacteria or amoeba
thank you for listening
and hope to see you next time